You can review the instructions.
You can press space for it to play, and you can pause also pressing space.
Okay, so do I just talk?
Yeah, talk and what you're feeling, what you're thinking.
Okay.
I was rushed, very nervous and tense.
And the mats were very slippery.
Start to focus in here.
My legs weren't stable, still pretty cold.
Everything felt really rushed, just looking back at the video.
I thought it was pretty good, but looking back, couldn't have done better.
Everything is a little too rushed.
And lost balance.
Moving to Second Mini.
This was actually very steep.
I mean the road was straight.
You can get to practice as soon as it's ready.
Make sure to switch on yourенти specifically.
Teksting av Nicolai Winther